the biggest sale of the year is
officially here black friday g fuel bogo
sale it's time to stock up you buy one
you get one great deal we have the new
pewdiepie shaker cup in black baby
looking
it's so exclusive i don't even have it
yet god damn they also have the black
friday reskin edition which looks hella
nice god damn look at that y'all know i
love g fuel i drink it every single day
it gives me that nice clean energy boost
not those annoying ones where you go oh
i'm hyper now
it tastes
amazing it gives you a nice clean boost
and it helps you support your favorite
creators that's right the why not mix
and match your favorite flavors you can
get the pewdiepie original one
and the pewdiepie user one both amazing
flavors
i mean the original one is the greatest
flavor of all time there will never be
anything that beats this but the usual
one is a nice clean change of paste that
i also love
beautiful so if you buy this you get
this for free it's also a great chance
to try out different flavors like blue
eyes hyped sauce miami knight is really
good that's the fun of g field there's
so many different flavors and they all
taste amazing so yeah use the link in
the description to take advantage of the
sale definitely don't want to miss out
on this one great cans hey pick up some
gifts stock up link in the description
thank you g fuel today we're checking
out the most common misconceptions in
the world we're about to broaden our
brain or to see how dumb we are did you
know chinese fortune cookies aren't
actually chinese
they're japanese
changes your whole outlook on life
doesn't they okay okay
check this out i found this wikipedia
page and it has it has it all it's i'm
blowing my mind i bet you didn't know
this
jesus was most likely not born on
christmas december it's more likely he
was important other seasons spring or
summer
christmas is cancelled
are you kidding me how did they mess
that up come on oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah
oh yeah i remember hearing this my
entire life and i could never make sense
out of it i'm so glad the great wall of
china is not the only human-made object
visible from space from the moon
who came up with that
why did people believe that
have you seen how how slim it is how
would you possibly see it
it makes no sense like if it was this
giant ball and yeah we could probably
see it right
city lights however are easily visible
on the night side they i mean yeah
it all adds up but that's still kind of
cool you think about it the sun is
actually white rather than yellow it is
atmospheric scattering that causes the
sun to look yellow orange or red at
sunrise and sunset huh
i thought the sun was black
hold on am i crazy
i thought that was like a physic physics
concept where it's a black body the sun
emits a black body spectrum
you know what
i'm not going to spread any more
misconceptions while trying to debug
misconceptions thank you very much
okay it's white it's white fine whatever
dogs do not sweat by salivating dogs
actually have sweat clients they sweat
mainly through their foot pants thank
you another thing i could never make
sense out of okay
i don't believe i just don't believe it
i don't know why i can't explain i don't
believe it i believe they sweat thank
you i've seen a sweaty boy when my dogs
lay on the couch and they get real warm
and and fuzzy
they ooze that wet smell like skunk
smell
gunky dunky funky smell i'm like they
sweat they definitely sweat thank you
wikipedia idiots
who will say dogs don't sweat they
definitely sweat idiot there's no
evidence that vikings wore horns on
their helmets
that would have been highly impractical
in battle
no
what what's next they're going to say
that vikings didn't they didn't drink
out of the skull of the vanquish enemies
they didn't name iceland
lies
liberal lies what is this oh my bad okay
they gave its name but they didn't do it
to discourage others from settling it
okay we're fine and you know what
i don't care what this says i'm gonna
believe at least one viking put horns on
their helmet and said that looks cool
so it counts in my head even though i
made it up
and i bet you at least one of these
[ __ ] skull and was like ah
that's good i bet you i bet you you
can't prove me you can't prove that it's
not true so therefore i will believe it
is true idiot
i'm the i'm the whole reason this stupid
wikipedia page has to exist like it's
baffling how much misconceptions there
are look at this shooting two guns at
the same time looks cool but it's like
impossible apparently how hard can it be
get out of here i can do that this one
kind of blew my mind because i still see
it in movies you must wait 24 hours
before reporting a missing person my
entire life every goddamn movie says it
if you have a genuine concern you should
contact the police immediately
like what the hell
you serious
yeah it actually makes sense that isn't
there a thing where like by every hour
that that it takes when the child is
missing the less likely they are to find
the kid right
so if anything you want to contact the
police as quick as possible to increase
your chances of finding the child
chloroform immediately knocks out people
for several hours no the truth is it
takes five minutes
what to feel the chemicals effect it
then lasts for a short time are you
serious can you imagine someone trying
to kidnap someone then they just pull up
with this i'm like
[ __ ] you doing stop it
well it's good it smells like sharpie
thing i like it what the hell
drowning victims usually call for help
loudly while reaching their arms up i
don't know actually it's hard to notice
a drowning person yeah i actually almost
drowned once i mean not not really but
as a naive person i am i remember in the
we were swimming and i was i don't know
a baby and you have those are
those pads on your arms to swim i didn't
know how to swim but i decided one day
i'm old enough to swim without the pads
but jumped in without anyone looking
without them and clearly i was drowning
right away and it was re i remember so
vividly like trying to pull from my dad
and i couldn't do it so yeah i almost
died
a door can be unlocked with a gun a
padlock shackle is thick and made of
iron a small bullet could wouldn't break
it really
well that ruins video games as well
you're joking get out of here and you
know what that kind of pisses me off now
because every time i get stuck by those
sometimes they show up and you're like
god damn there's a locked door and i
don't have a key ah so annoying and the
game just wants you to shoot it right
but you don't think about it because of
this because you couldn't do it that's
right my brain was right all along i am
not dumb for not thinking of the puzzle
thank you napoleon was short he was
actually
5'7 which was slightly taller than the
average frenchman at that time
thank you
another thing that i didn't know if it
was true or not but it just annoyed me
the fact that people said it because
people love to say napoleon was short
right one of the greatest war generals
of our time few people in our history
will ever compare and people are just
like reducing him did you know
he was kind of short
he's like what the [ __ ] what is that
you think that places you anywhere above
him like shut the [ __ ] up god damn
appreciate christopher columbus first
discovered america no it was norse
missionary named late ericsson well if i
ever heard a swedish name that's it
sweden invented america
you're [ __ ] welcome [ __ ] or are you
i don't know
i knew vikings discovered uh america
before which is really badass if you
think about it it was a north explorer
just don't tell me he was norwegian
please he was born in iceland no that
makes no sense you're gonna tell me
vikings didn't have those cool ass
things now too
stop it
you must wait 30 minutes after eating
there's no risk of muscle crimes if you
another thing that always annoys me i'm
like why why can't why can't i go in the
pool
you just egg felix you can't go in the
pool but yeah but why oh because your
muscle how does that work oh my god this
is pissing me
excuse apparently i mean it's having
multiple personalities no to be confused
with multiple personalities or
schizophrenia involves disorders
thoughts psychosis and delusion i like
this because it's like hollywood says we
need to be inclusive and everyone that
is this should play this and but also
hollywood completely misrepresents
someone's mental disorder into a plot
device well done
you only use 10 of your brain brain
scans have shown that no matter what
someone is doing all brain areas are
active to some degrees huh well god damn
i guess there's no hope for us dumb ones
huh
i always thought that
yes
turning on the interior light while
driving is illegal
it is not illegal but it doesn't make it
harder to see the road and can cause
distracted driving
no it no i don't even believe that get
out of here
it's funny because martial still wants
me to turn up the light parents just
said it was illegal because if you turn
on the lights in the back right as a
child you do that when you want to play
on the game boy that didn't have any
internal lights built into it so you
physically couldn't play a game boy
unless there was a light mom okay
but yeah then we forget to turn it off
so the other day the next day when your
parents drive the car they're like oh
super child forgot to turn up the light
that's irritating
that is made enough that it was illegal
god damn it oh my
cats and dogs are colorblind i never
believe this either they're mostly sea
shades of blue gray yellow much like a
human with red green
[Music]
what's that dogs aren't colorblind they
see blue-green yellow just like human
every time
every time we watch shark tank and i got
them shark swings by or anything blue
for that matter edgar loses it no way i
know it
yes
this smells good now
what's happening
edgar
what are you doing
you can see color red guy that's amazing
congratulations i knew it stupid oh
you're here now you want to come here
okay come here oh you're so sleepy
i've been trying to tell you ferris i
can see cars i can shoot them just fine
all right bro let's check out more well
now they're saying the sun is green
buddha is the god of buddhism
gatama possessed no godly powers and
encouraged self-reliance self-discipline
and individual striving i remember when
i was younger you thought he was like
some sort of uh crazy being tennis fans
are always random the penny will land
tails up 80 percent of the time
lincoln's head makes the head side
heavier making the coin more likely to
fall with that side down
eighty percent
that's an important fact to know
actually is that true i can't even tell
if i'm reading the myth or the d but
eighty percent i don't know if i i don't
know i don't know
no
pets or tails well i guess always pick
tails then
the familiar story that isaac newton was
inspired
to research the nature of gravity by an
apple hitting his head is almost
certainly
apocryphal
all newton himself ever said that the
idea came to him as he sat in a
contemplative mood and was occasioned by
the fall of an apple bro if i lived
isaac newton time
easy easy i'd be like bro gravity
this invisible force all right listen
how do you i was the kind of child child
i thought well if i lift up one leg why
can't i lift up my other leg and like
flying
yeah but yeah i will die
there you have it don't you feel smarter
now
now when other people bring all this
stuff up you can go hey i watch
pewdiepie i can tell you all about
subscribe for more epic information see
you tomorrow profess